Back in March, Twitter suspended the
account of the massively popular
Christian satire site The Babylon
Bee after it awarded "Man
of the Year" honors to Rachel
Levine, a transwoman serving in
the Biden administration's
Department of Health and Human
Services who had been named one of
USA Today's "Women of
the Year." The Babylon Bee's editor
in chief, Kyle Mann, says that
the article was intended to satirize
media treatment of identity
politics, not demean trans
people.
We love trans people and we love
you know, we don't we don't consider
people like that beneath us.
You know, the Christian worldview is
that everybody everybody has the
opportunity to be saved, you know,
and we can love everybody.
And I'm no more deserving of God's
grace than a transgender person.
But when the culture
bows down and starts handing out
trophies to people for stuff like
this, that's when we say, 'Hey, wait
a minute, we need to protect women
in our society as well.'
The Bee's Twitter account remains
locked because the publication
steadfastly refuses to delete
the tweet and acknowledge it
contravened Twitter's policy against
hate speech in response to the
Twitter ban and persistent
demonetization and minimizing of
the reach of its content at
Facebook, the Bee has created its
own social network and subscription
model, both of which are
flourishing.
The episode shines a light on how
contemporary culture wars are waged
online and illustrates the
specific travails that
evangelical Christians face
in a country that is increasingly
secular and socially liberal.
Reason caught up with Mann at
Freedom Fest, the annual gathering
in Las Vegas, to talk about why he
loves making fun of Donald Trump
and Joe Biden, but saves his deepest
burns for megachurch pastors such
as Joel Osteen.
Why he believes that the left and
Gen Z can't deal with humor
that makes fun of them and why he
loves personal liberty and personal
freedom, even if it creates a
culture that is deeply hostile
to his faith.